我们会着重的去看相关的一些hi呀
以及渲染的一些代码
今天呢是第一讲
那么我们一开始呢会先回顾一下
简单的去回顾一下图形渲染的一些渲染
管线的基础知识
我们会看一个地下12的基本案例
去了解一下一个完整的渲染图形渲染的流程
然后因此从然后从那里去总结
hi的一些关键的要素
然后回过头来去看U1里面
他是怎么把它封装起来的
因为U1他要做的目标是要做跨平台
他不只是说实现第第三
D12或者是一某一种就可以了
他要实现的是啊
把DX11
Dx12
Open jail
metal van等各种各样的呃的平台
它都把它封装成统一的一个接口
封装成统一的一套流程
那么这个东西呢就是所谓的hi
那么就是渲染了一个U1里面的一个接口层
那么我们最重要的是要了解到
他为什么会这样子去封装对吧
我们如果有一个这样子的目标也很清晰哦
知道哦
他就是一想这样子去封装
那我们看代码就会快很多啊
嗯好我们先从一开始哈
我们先从这个GPU的那个渲染管线开始
回顾一下哈
那么首先一个完整的渲染流程
或者是一次做客
第一次做空
他要执行的步骤
GPU里面是定好了
就是这张图哈
从左往右
左边呢呃从顶点开始哈
从顶点的输入开始
然后会做重要的第一个部分
就是我们常说的顶点着色器VX
然后如果有有的话
会做一些什么
就match c的啊等等哈
然后呢会做裁解
会做光栅化
裁剪跟光栅化呢是我们控制不了的
就是啊GPU已经定好的
就是我们没办法去控制的
就是红色的这个流程呢是GPU定好的
然后呢工商化之后就会变成一个个像素了哈
一个个像素我们就会执行啊像素着色器
然后最后就做一些深度检测啊
抗锯齿之类的
最后呢还有一个后期处理
然后最后就输出
那么这样子
一次做客就要经历所有的这么多步骤
才能最终输出到一张贴图
或者是输出到我们的屏幕上好
那么我们怎么写代码
我们能写什么代码
我们能写的代码就是这些绿色的
绿色的流程是我们可以通过编程代码去控制的
就是说我们可以把都按照GPU
按照D3D12或者open g
或者其他按照他规定的格式
我们去书写对应的代码
然后上传到GPU里面去
GPU到时候我们发起一次做客的时候
它就会执行对应的代码
那么所有的程序都一样哈
所有的程序都一样
就是有三件事情
第一件事情是代码本身
第二事情是用到什么样子的参数
你要有哪些输入的数据
数据的格式
第三是真正的数据
因为因为我们这些写的代码
我们的输入是可以不一样的
所以我们不仅是要只是把真正的数据传进去
我们还要在事先把代码传给GPU的时候
先把输入的数据格式也要告诉GPU
GPU才能理解好
那我们对着一个第第三题
12的案例来来说一下
就很明显了哈
呃这个呢就是这个是龙叔的付那个代码哈
龙叔的案例哈
嗯这个呢就是着色器的代码啊
那么在最底下首先是两个函数
一个是PX
一个是VX
那么就是对对应管线里面的
pixel shader跟vertex shader哈
那么呃具体的代码我们不用管
我们只是知道它是一段啊书写好的代码
然后呢他要处理输入
最后返回输出
处理输入返回输出好经过他的
经过我们自己写的代码可以直接控制
那也就是说有一轮代码
然后呢还有我们输入输出的格式
输入输出的格式
然后还有我们用到的一些全局的变量参数
那简单来说反正它就是一段内存
是一段参数
那么我们用到了B0B1B二
你别的代码
别的着色器可能用到的更多
或者是根本就更少
或者是不一样
你可以加参数
减参数都可以的
因此呢GPU去执行我们这段程序呢
把这段程序放在这个流程里面去执行的时候
我们第一件事要做什么
除了把第一件事当然是把代码传进去了
对不对
编译好上传进去
第二件事还要与此同时告诉编译器
我们代码的参数格式
最后真正执行之前
我们第三还要把那个数据传进去
就三件事
所以我们其实的渲染程序
其实也没有那么复杂哈
看起来很多东西
但是我们了解就三个人不是那么对
一对一D三D12里面
那么它的代码跟参数格式呢
就是在这个pipeline day里面哈
这是一个pipeline day的一个一个这样子的对象哈
就是我们要创建一个pines day
一个pines day就是一个广线的所有状态
就是说这个对象它代表了整一个从左往右
所有流程的一个定制啊
包括它的代码
他的代码格式
以及某些流程里面用到的一些设置状态
那么就是你你全部弄好
当然了
如果你要执行不同的着色器代码
那你就要用
你就要按照不同的配置
要创建不同的pipeline st
然后你到时候就告诉他
我要用哪个pipeline day去执行就OK了
所以呢其实就是要去创建一个这样的papa
我们看到他创建之前要要搞一堆参数哈对吧
搞这么一堆参数
那这两个就是把代码编译好的代码放进去
把编译好的代码放进去
那么他当然就是一段内存啦
这一内存的指针跟一个size哈
然后呃还有一堆各种各样的状态的一些设置
各种各样状态的一些设置
然后呢还有这个跟签名里面
所谓的跟签名
就是其实就是对应这个代码的一些
输入参数格式
那么他先先封装成一个根签名再放进来哈
那根签名里面就是长这样子哈
根签名
跟清明之力
那我们的常函数有哪些
我们的强项数是有T0X0B0B1B二对吧
有五个参数
当然了
这个sampler是特殊的
所以它叫额外地方设置
那么其他的呢这种是有四个
那么对应就是这里有四个参数
按照他的格式
我告诉他我有四个参数
注意这里并不是真的把参数的值传进去哈
是只是告诉他一个参数的格式哈
那么这个其实就相当于是啊
我这个参数第零个常州是一个DESCRIPTABLE哈
对应就是一张贴图哈
然后三个constant buffer哈
三个constant buffer view哈
那么就是B0B1B二哈
就告诉他我有三呃
我我有这么多个参数哈
那这个SAMPER是另外一个地方设置的啊
就是这样
那么构造完这个东西呢之后呢
就把这个东西打包成一个root signature的一个
description dee s c哈
然后把它打包好一个描述哈用了
然后就用这个描述去真正的去创建
一个更签名哈
所以你明白根签名其实就是着色器的输入格式
对吧
他当然有很多东西去设置
但我们其实只要明白
我们就是要把根签名
就是主设计的一个输入格式
然后到时候还要去用它来生成
我们那个pipeline day
然后呢这这两件事执行完了之后
我们去真正真的去驱动GPU
是执行代码的时候
就是一个draw哈
一个JOJO
就是
我们看一下做的行情
这里就是每一帧我们去去驱动GPU去执行的时候
我们就是要告诉他
你要用我们刚才创建的那个pipeline day哈
那个那个渲染管线的状态哈
就是所有东西哈
其实这句话就是告诉他啊
OK现在我们要绑定用用这个PSO哈
当然你可以用别的
就是说你你执行不同的着色器的代码对吧
那它不同的着色器代码用的参数不一样
那么你就是相当于是你你不同的着色器的代码
你就创建各种各样不同的这个pipeline day哈
到时候你要用的时候
你就你就告诉告诉GPU啊
OK我先先立下回我要这样子哈
用它
然后呢嗯那么用这个peline day跟这个LOSNATURE哈
都要设置好啊
那就其实就相当于是
那这个这个时候GGPU显卡就知道代码在哪里啦
代码的格式是怎样子的
那剩下一件事是什么
把参数传进去
当然了
中间还有很多其他的状态啊
这个这个这个不用理哈
这个我们重点不在这里
你就按照龙叔的格式去了解一下就可以了
那么比如说我们要真的把参数设置进去
比如说
这是一个float4K
这个值到底是多少呢
对吧
这个这个浮点数
这个向量它的值是1111还是2222
还是0.00几呀
它的值是多少呢
我们还要把真正的插入的值传进去
那么真正的值传进去就是这个哈
这个set这个什么constant buffer view哈
就是说我们先把真正的参数啊
当然了
我们并不是直接把值传进去
我们还有一些把这些值呃
upload GPU里面变成一段cos buffer啊
你这这个就是一个虚拟的指针哈
虚拟的指针哈
watchat address哈
虚拟的地址哈
就是我们事先还要在别的地方
先把一一这个真正的值其实就是移动内存对吧
移动内存上传到GPU里面
那就变成一段显存
它在某个地方啊对吧
然后然后我们这个时候就要真的设置进去
就会告诉他啊
值在那里
当然里面还有哈
在这个里面还会设置其他的那个参数啊
比如说这个贴图对吧
就是这段代码里面的第一个参数啊
贴图这个T0它不是用了一张贴图吗
贴图在哪里呀
我们也要把贴图的东西全告诉他啊
这个贴图啊
还有刚才那个那个B1和B3
BBB2B这个哈B0B1B二哈对吧
把这些参数传进去好
那么是不是现在所有的东西都解决完了
这解决完了
最后怎么办
最后就告诉CPU说
OK你可以去执行了
那么就是一个draw哈
为什么我们说一个渲染管线就是一个ZQ哈
其实就是你把所有东西准备好
然后就调一个做到GPU
就到时候就会把这个东西命令去执行
就正确的去炫耀了哈
啊
还有还有另外一个这个顶点的属性也是要的哈
这个顶点的属性
刚才我们说的这些参数是全局的参数哈
还有这个顶点的属性是每个顶点都不一样
每个顶点都不一样
也是要把值传进去哈
那就是就是这两个哈嗯
这个这个这个这个这个这个这个这个嘛
顶点顶点的一个buffer跟索引的buffer传进去
然后是告诉大三角形的类型就OK了
呃我们不用太关注这些具体的参数的一些格式
我们不用太过于关注
我们只要想明白一件事情
我们现在的目标是什么
U1准备要怎么样去封装这些东西
U1所以就是三件事
各种呃代码代码的格式以及各种各样的参数
各种各样的设置状态
那么所有的参数和设置状态我们都是什么
本质就是一段内存或者是一段显存对吧
就是一个D3D12的resource资源
那么在第3D里面是移动resource资源
同样道理
在open gl里面也是哈
你把这一段内存传进去
然后我本就有机会返回一个无符号的整数啊
其实就是一个resource的ID啊
对吧好我们
所以呢我们就会去卷子去封装
因此呢因此走到了这个
a hi的封装
我们自然而然第一个问题就是这些资源吧
那么所有在U1里面
所有这种资源的积累
就是它f i h i resource
就是代表了一个资源
一个抽象的资源
他不还没有还没有具体到是某些资源
资源可以是什么
可以是一个buffer
constant buffer加UE里面就是uniform Buff
uniform buffer可以是张贴图
一个texture
还有各种各样什么sample啊
或者是什么
还有甚至连各种呃其他的一个什么state
一个状态啊
就是都是一个resource
都是一个resource
那么鸡肋里面我们看一下这个代码
我们现在开始看代码的话
要认真一点
鸡肋里面它其实没有定义太多的东西
它首先只是定义了一些left啊
destroy跟历史就是这样子的函数
它没有更多的东西
还没有更多的东西呃
还有个原子插座哈
因为这个原子插座最大
那么还有一些嗯这个什么mask1些东西啊
不用就是一些数据吧哈
Ok
没有了结束了
它有两个变量
有一个是resource type
Resource type
我们看一下这个枚举值有什么
你看我有什么什么是resource
有simple day
Simpliday
还有各种各样的day是吧
还有C的各种各样的C的state
还有buffer
Buffer
就是呃呃我们刚才那些B0B1B二是吧
还有贴图对吧
各种各样的贴图
还有一些VIP
Thanks query
这些全部都是全部都是i hi so的类型啊
那我们大概有个了解这些东西
我们这里的每一样
这里面的每一个类型
我们都会呈现出type对应的一个HI的类型
你看i hi的类型
所以我们现在这个i h i source呢就是一个鸡肋
它没有定义任何的东西
而他也不跟open gl或者是D3D12没有关联啊
没有关联
它是个抽象的概念
呃那比如说我们可以了解一下嗯
一个uniform buffer吧
一个uniform buffer
那对应其实就是一段内内存或者一段显存
它我们看一下
A f r h i u from buffer
一个uniform buffer继承了resource
注意我们现在定义的这个i hi的uniform buffer
是通用的
并不是D3D12里面的
也不是open gl里面的
因此呢他在里面
在这个uniform buffer里面也还没有真正的实现
它只是定义的对外的接口
你怎么用一段uniform Buff
它定义的也很简单
就是一个release
还有一个size的多大
还有一些layout呃
差不多
所以呢他也并你面对一个uniform Buff
其实就是这些就足够了
但是真正的实现是怎么做的呢
在U1里面它是怎么实现这样一套思路呢
它是通过几子类继承它去实现的
也就是说他f r h r uniform buffer
代表的是一种通用的跨平台的uniform buffer
那么真正的实现是什么
是比如说D3D12里面就会继承uniform buffer
去实现一个D3D12的子类
open gl也会去实现一个它的子类
到时候我们编译引擎代码的时候
如果现在你是用open gl去编译
它
就会使用所有的open jo的子类去创建这个对象
那当然你上面用起来
因为它是继承关系
所以你上面它也是一个rh i uniform buffer
用起来就是一个RHIUNIBUFFER
但是它实际底层可能就是
根据你不同编译的情况选择生成不同的的子类
那么它比如说这个r j r uniform buffer
我们看一下它的子类
就是嗯
看像是FD三D12uniform buffer
那他见他就是继承了这个rhi uniform Buff
这个就是D3D12里面真正的实现
因为我们知道
如果是D3D12里面的一段buffer其实是什么
最终其实是一个D3D12的resource
对不对
你把内存上传进去
在GPU里面已经上传到GPU里面了
你能拿到一个什么东西
代表它就是一个D3D12的resource
的一个指针
那它具体存在哪里呢
它就存在这个里面的这个resource
location这个成员变量里面哈
他这个uniform Buff
第三第16有一个location的的全员变量哈
他把D3D12的所有resource
都抽象出一个location
location里面
实际上就是会有一个成年边界叫居resource哈
应该叫比较底下
对这个这个resource resource里面有什么
你说你说里面就是真正的第三次
E12的resource的指针哈
那这个就是真正的真正的那一段
在D3D12里面的一个真正存储的
resource的指针
还有对呀
当然这里还有其他什么UAV啊
heap啊之类的
还有这个GPU watch address啊
它直接把它存储起来啊
直接把它存储起来
因为我们用的时候很多
如果是D3D12
我们现在很多用的时候就直接在别的接口
可能直接要用用这个watch address哈
所以呢现在我们回过头来看一个
就是说你rh i uniform buffer
是i hi层面的一个通用的代表类
我通过继承它子类去实现真正的功能对吧
我们在这里面会有他
在这里面会在这个成员变量的成员变量里面
会有真正的D3D12的resource
以及他的那些virtual js对吧
那你想要实现什么接口
我们就在hi里面前面定义一个接口
然后在子类里面去实现它就行了嘛
是不是比如说你要释放这段资源
或者是创建这个资源
或者是呃upload1段东西
一段内存进去
我们就会定义接口去upload进去
然后真正的实现也是在D3D12里面的好
那比如说你要去到open gl里面
是不是也有一个呢
当然也有
那它就是f open gl uniform Buff
就是他如果你选择了编译
用open jo去编译
那么到时候这个HI的对象
它底层里面创建的时候
它就会按创建open gl的uniform buffer
那么在open g里面的资源
所有的东西它就是一个无符号的整数
所以它定义起来比较简单
open gl定义起来比较简单
它就是一个无符号的整数
就是你创建完它OBG2里面
那个可能a resource之后创建完
然后它会返回一个无符号的整数
那个其实其实说是这个资源的id或者是什么
反正你你把这个id
你在任何时候需要用到这个resource
你就把这个id传过去
各种各样的接口它就可以了
所以是这个呃
其他的我们也先不用理哈
所以你比如说你要真如果是open g2编译
到时候你要copy这一段内存
或者是上传一段到GPU里面的缓存或者是怎么样
那到时候你就拿着这个resource的值
按照open区域里面的ABI接口去去实现就行了
他也在open g了
这对于这一套里面去实现了各种各样的东西
好我们再回过头来
所以其实我们现在已经有一个有一个很清晰
有一个很清晰的概念了哈
知道呃
hi里面的实现封装的思路哈
那么继承这个i h i d source的大类呢
有很多很多哈
超级多的哈
你看在这个代码里面哈哈就
几千行哈
几千行啊
封装了无数个各种各样的哈
那比如说甚至连C的都是哈
那连着色器
着色器是它的一个一个子类哈
然后各种各样GRAVC的VOC的这些
你会看到它它其实都没有什么实现的出
第一次看代码的人可能会有点奇怪
怎么继承了他
然后又没用了呢
呃因为这里是RHI里面的定义
RHI里面的定义是自定义一个通用的鸡肋
我也就是说这个是代表了一个HI层面
到时候你用它就可以了
你不用关注它
因为真正的实现是在各种各样
第三第12
第三题11
Open gel
还有metal van
各种各样会继承他去实现一个每一个平台
都会去实现一个它的子类
跟那个uniform Buff一样
你看uniform buffer它会有open jer的子类
它会有D3D12的子类
看你编译你怎么编译
你用不同的编译
它就是使用不同的那个那一套
同样道理
这些所有的资源
这些所有的资源都会有对应的一套
比如说我们在看
为了第一次看可能不太熟悉
我们再看多一个案例嗯
我们看什么
看贴图
贴图也是我们很常用的
我们app texture贴图是继承web resource
WEBSOURCE是间接继承了埃及阿里索斯啊
所以呢texture诶怎么跳到这里来了
所以i hi texture它也是resource的子类
然后texture它也并还并没有真正的实现
这是i hi全面
它定义的是接口
定义的是接口
get他的描述或者是呃
当然他可以直接get到最底层的native lisource哈
定义一些size哈
怎么拿到他的size啊对吧
还有这个什么Mac demension啊
诸如此类
还有一些这些就是我对一张贴图的各种操作哈
拿到他的那个默认值哈对吧
珠子类呃
还有一个名字是吧
Get the science
Get a for ma
但是他并没有在这个类里面真正的去实现
它
并没有在这里面去实现
更多的是定义好
就是接口在i hi层面提供这样一个操作的方法
在上层逻辑呢
就比如说你如果是写上层逻辑代码的
你拿到这个I就I就OK了
你也不用管到底是open gl还是D3D12的
你就调它的函数就能去实现对应的功能了
你所以呢你写的代码呢就自动的编译
open gl的时候
它也能运行
编译第3D12的它也能运行啊
这个是给上层逻辑用的
是它定义的是这样一个套路哈
同样道理他也有一个
呃比如说open gl f open gl
open gl也继承了i hi teacher
去真正用open gl没去去实现哈
去实现
比如说啊他它的LESOURCE就是一个无符号整数啊
在open gl里面都是一个无符号整数吧
就比如说呃
我们找一些常见的
哦它的实现是在另外一个dynamir gr里面
Ok
那那反正我们知道open g2里面的保存着
真正的open gu里面的resource的这个id啊
520整数以及其他真正的去实现哈
要又比如说在D3D12里面
FD三D12texture
那它也是继承i hi texture哈去实现它
当然了
他他所有的东西也是放在一个那个resource
location啊
这个它同时也是这个base resource这个子子类哈
所以呢它真正的东西也是一个这个
Resource location
那刚才我们uniform Buff的时候也看到了哈
在第三第12里面
所有的资源都是一个resource哈
一个D3D12的resource哈
所以它它直接抽象成一个location啊
这里面就会有他哈
所以这张贴图贴图就包含在这里面哈
所以
第三题12的texture
就包含了真正的第三题12里面的实现哈
那么这个就是呃HIPHONE中的一个思路
八宅风中的一个思路呃
比如说有什么好处呢
有什么好处
我们看一下我们最常见的那个U
这个是我们上层逻辑最熟悉的tech
就是纹理
就是写蓝图的时候
你用到的那个PTURE
其实是他为什么我们需要一层i hi的封装呢
是因为你封装好之后
你就不用写D3D12的代码
你也不用写open gl的代码
比如说我们要去更新这张贴图的内存对吧
更新一张贴图
他应该提供了一个update update函数啊
我们讲一下
啊对对
它提供了一个update texture哈
就是说你你把这个贴图的大小格式
以及真正的数据对吧
数据的大小
真正的东西传进去
他就帮你做
它实际上里面是怎么做的呢
实际上就是调i hi的一个函数哈
嗯啊这个是它的实现在里面就是这个哈
它是要到render里面去
这就是他看到没有
它就是实现了一个hi update2D的一个方法
这个方法呢是定义在
command list里面的哈
OK那我们先呃它进一步里面是定义在hi里面了
这个
呃
我们看一下它
你也知道
诶怎么又跳回来了
这个类对dynamic hi
这也是一个非常重要的
RHI层面的一个最最最最重要之一的一个类哈
我们马上就要去看浏览一下它哈
就是说在这个类里面
它定义了那个更新贴图的方法
但是在这个类里面
所有的函数它都是类似这样子的
并没有真正的去实现哈
它同样这个类也有一个D3D12的子类
好open之类的子类和各种各样的子类
我们
看一下这个update哈
那这个update test在第三第12里面是他啊
就是他它会实现一个D3D12的DYNAMIHI
他是那个i hi的子类
那这个这个是间接哈
就是那这个再上一层
那就是继承这个dynamic i hi的
这个是i hi层面定义的一个接口类
接口类
它定义了很多方法
然后包括我们刚才要呃
更新一张贴图的那个方法
update texture的那个region的那个方法
那它真正的实现在D3D12里面
就是在这个子类里面去实现的
在这个子类去实现的就是这个好方法
在这个之类才真正的去实现了
这个update touch2D的方法
它里面的调用
就是直接按照D3D12的去调用
它就是那个这里我们直接跳进去就可以看到
纯延伸的调用
大概是joy
这个
这个就是就是真正的
这个已经是第三第12的方法了哈
第三第12哈
看到第三第12的接口方法了哈
copy region哈
所以呢它其实最终就是会调调这个同样的道理
在open gu里面也实现了这个东西
open gu里面实现的是他
他也有一个open gl的dynamic hi
他也是dynamic hi的之类
然后继承它实现它
那继承它
他还间接继承了好多层啊
他这个一层层继承了
中间有好多层
我们不用现在不用关注
所以呢他在open gu里面也继承他实现这个方法
那么它自然而然他就是要调open gu里面的
那个更新的函数哈
包括这些什么一堆啊
你看到这些JO开头的
那就已经是JO名的那个方法了哈
好呃
到这个位置
我们就已经有一个
应该已经有一个大概的概念了哈
我们呃一段GPU里面的程序
那我们要封装它各种各样的操作方法
封装它各种各样的资源
那么资源呢就有很多
我们刚才已经浏览过了
就是那个h i source有H各种啊
Hi texture
I hi uniform buffer
那么这个是在i hi前面的各种类
那然后在这个基础上
每一个平台D三D11D二零十二
open gl都会去实现它一个真正的子类
去用不同的平台的语言去实现它
好那资源了解完了之后
刚才我们已经看到了这个
我们说这个类很重要哈
因为很多操作都是这个资源定义的
这个dynamage hi就是定义了各种各样的操作
包括我们说更新一张纹理
刚才看我已经看了
我们现在要浏览一下它定义的方法
他这里只是定义的方法
大体全部都是这样子
没有去实现的呃
比如说去创建一个samples day
创建一个rust stay depp dcs
stay各种各样的创建这种stay
创建各种各样的C得对吧
Computer
还有这种创建这种什么query pool fans是吧
还有
那创建这种什么boss day1堆哈
Pipeline day
创建这种啊
我们
呃创建uniform buffer对吧
很多哈
这个类很多很多很多很多很多太多了
这就是说一些常见的图形
渲染里面的一些操作啊
创建一些纹理
创建一些呃状态
创建一些资源或者是更新资源
或者是设置设置
创建一些F或者是更新贴图啊
就是一些长卷的这种图形的操作就都很多哈
嗯差不多一大半吧
都定义在这一个dynamihi i hi里面
它定义了这样的一个操作接口
然后open gl会去继承它
实现它
第三的时候也会继承它去实现它
那我们应该应该已经有一个
有一个很清晰的了解了哈
那么资源就这就是这么定义的
那么接下来就是
怎么去执行对吧
111段一段操作
那么就是会继续去实现一个command呃
这个我们
东西有点多啊
我们今天先第一讲
就先到这个位置
先建立一个大概的印象
IHI它的封装思路一句话定义积累
然后在不同的平台实现积累
然后在上层逻辑就是不用管
就是比如说你你如果是用上层
你写上层逻辑
你就是用hi的函数就OK了
千万不要在这里面自己写自己的D3D12哈
那那到时候你的代码就不能跨平台了哈
你一定在上层逻辑
你就像一个这个u texture啊
就像蓝图的这U我们常见的UT曲啊
你就是用IHI的函数去调用就OK了
它在自然而然它在不同的平台里面
有对应的实现
那在不同的平台去编译的时候
它自然而然就自动的用不同平台的去实现
去去触发
那
这个就是hi的一个封装思路哈
我们今天呢就是先复习一些基础的知识
了解1i hi的大概的实现思路
后面还有很多哈
所以一下子讲不完哈
我们马上第二讲
第三讲呢我们就会讲呃
他具体的一些命令
comb common list的执行
然后会讲seed seed
怎么一些卡的一些代码的的细节哈
OK我们今天先讲这么多哈
时间有点长